the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good morning everybody uh welcome to
today's presentation on advanced order
flow trading made
easy my name is michael baltos i'm the
founder and
trader at orderflows.com now
you know just get a few things out of
the way yes this session
will be recorded and
yeah i do have a special treat for you
guys at the end if you stick around
so you know there's still a few people
coming on it just turned 10 o'clock
so um you know what i'll be talking
about today in this training
is is a few things right you know order
flow has been around for
a long time and you know
unfortunately a lot of people still have
a
basic knowledge of order flow they
haven't really advanced their
education so to speak you know their
trading education
with order flow and you know i find it
to be
shocking and a shame at the same time
because
there's so much information for a trader
to get
out of the order flow that they could
use in their trading
so in today what you're going to
discover is how to use order flow in
different market conditions
i'm going to share with you a couple
advanced order flow trade setups and
we'll explain them to you so
you know whether you're using software
that i developed or software
from another party you know hopefully
you can take what you
learned today and apply it to the
markets
using your existing order flow software
personally i'm a bit biased i think mine
is superior to a lot of the other
software out there
but you know i want you to come away
with something that you can use
in your trading no matter what all right
and i'm going to talk about
the tools that you can use to make order
flow
trading easier right i mean that's the
whole point of
trading is you know to make it easy to
see what's happening in the market you
know
it's not about throwing indicator or
squiggly lines or trend lines or this
and that on a screen
and finding something that works usually
after the fact you want to know what's
happening right now
and that's what order flow helps you to
to see in the markets right so i want to
show you how to leverage the information
that's generated by the market right
what's actually trading
right now in the market so you're always
trading in the same
direction as the market right it sounds
simple but you know a lot of people keep
fighting the market right
they're trying to buy on a market that's
that keeps dropping or they keep
trying to get short on a market that's
rallying right like today in the s ps
right we were rallying this morning
after the cash open a nice strong rally
and
you know anybody that was trying to get
short on that is you know
left holding the bag so what makes order
flow different
than you know other forms of technical
analysis
well you got to realize order flow is
not the latest greatest fad in trading
it's been around for well over 100 years
you know one of the greatest books on
trading
uh you know that is referenced by a lot
of very successful traders as being very
influential on their trade or
development is reminiscence of a stock
operator
right but you got to remember that takes
place in the early 1900s
right that's a hundred years ago and he
was an order flow trader
right now granted in those days they
didn't have you know the computer
technology that we have today
everything came through on a ticker tape
but you know that was order flow
at that time that was what was
considered order flow now with the
advent of
computers especially personal computers
you know we're able to take that
information
and expand on it right
and you know that's really what order
flow is about and
this training today is for serious
traders that want to understand
what's actually happening in the market
now like i said you know i got a special
treat for you guys if you stick around
until the end i'm going to show you how
to get
this book that i wrote called trading
order flow
it's 150 page book that i wrote um you
know after i left jp morgan
you know i've spent 20 years you know as
a professional institutional
side trader okay and this is sort of you
know
i started writing this book because i
wanted to give back to
the trading world you know a lot of what
i learned because you know
it's hard nowadays for people to get
involved you know on a trading desk
right it's very difficult right you have
to go to a certain school you got to get
a certain
degree and sometimes you got to know the
right people whereas before you could
just go down to the exchange floor ask
around for a job and by the end of the
day
hopefully you would usually have one
right people came from all different
backgrounds now
you know it's very there's only finite
amount of jobs and there's so many
people competing
for them that you know you're really
better off learning how to trade
yourself you know the barrier to entry
for opening an account is much lower
than it was say 20 years ago
right commissions are very low relative
to 20 years ago 20 you know now
people are complaining about spending
five dollars a round trip
you know in the futures whereas you know
in the 90s
if you're paying 20 a round trip that
was considered
very cheap already so you know the
conditions have gone up and gone down
it's gone down
as far as opening an account and
learning how to trade and becoming a
trader for yourself
as opposed to getting a job on a trading
desk the barrier has gone
way up and it's very difficult so
in that book that i wrote trading order
flow i explained you know how to
read the order flow you know it it's in
you know and how professional traders
think
right the big institutional traders
think because at the end of the day
that's who you're really competing
against
you know you're not competing against
some other retail traders you're really
competing against the big boys
the guys with the deep pockets so
hopefully you know that book will give
you some insights
into you know how the institutional
traders trade
now what makes order flow again so
special is it gets you as close to the
market
as possible right so you can see what's
really happening in the market
and you know people think well just look
at a chart and that's going to give me
you know it's going to tell me what's
going on and it's just going to tell you
where price traded
it's not going to tell you how the
trading was was it aggressive
was it passive was there heavy volume
was there light volume
right what the market's really doing
right so order flow allows you to gauge
the tendency a market will continue in a
direction and that's important because
you know as the market starts moving in
a direction you want to know is that
move
strong or is it getting weaker right new
trading activity which is the volume
is what's going to keep the market
moving in a direction if that volume
starts getting lighter
chances are that moves not going to be
sustained and it's you're going to get
ready for a correction
and you know thirdly you know you're
gonna have better more complete
information
than 99 of the traders out there who are
only looking at the open high low close
and you know some may look at volume you
know once in a while
but your real advantage is going to be
by looking at information that other
traders
are not paying attention to so for those
that are new to one of my presentations
so just
a brief background on who i am i'm not
trying to make this you know about me or
anything
but understand where i come from right
i'm not
somebody that you know just picked up a
course on trading
and taught myself how to trade now i'm
teaching you no
i worked i started on the cme floor back
in the early 90s right with dean witter
reynolds as a runner literally at the
bottom right you can't start
any lower than that in that industry um
you know it's funny because you know the
cme you know
the runners when you start out right you
got a yellow jacket right members
obviously like the colorful jackets but
you know the the story was that you know
the
there was a woman who you know was on
the board of directors and said you know
the
those runners they have to wear a yellow
jacket
because they're peons i mean if you
understand you know peons it was
yellow p but anyway that's how low it
was right but
you know i worked my way up right i left
the trading floor when electronic
trading started taking off
in the early 90s with dean witter
reynolds still on their
upstairs trading desk okay after that i
joined edf man the big
english trading company right they've
been around since the 1700s so i trade
all
forms of soft commodities right after
that i joined commerce bank in chicago
i spent like four years there i was
there your ex traders their license urex
trader at that time to trade your ex in
the us
there was only certain companies that
could do it commerce bank was one of
of a handful at that time in the in the
late 90s
and you know it was great because i had
a i had a license
to trade your ex right it was in a sense
you know a membership at the exchange
through commerce bank but you know it
wasn't considered that but
i was the one that had the license so
nobody else at commerce bank
technically was allowed to except me
they had to trade
through me if they wanted to trade then
after commerce bank you know after 9 11
i took some time off six months i sort
of traveled around the world
then i joined cargill in chicago i
joined their futures trading desk
cargill the big american
commodity trading company versus edf man
which is the english one
and i spent four years there also and
they sent me out to singapore when the
exchange was closing their trading floor
the sgx exchange the old cymix exchange
wanted to go fully electronic it was at
that time it was basically one of the
last
few exchanges in the world that was
all um you know had the open outcry that
wanted to go fully electronic
so i went out there and i set up their
trading desk um
after that again i you know i was in
asia i'm in my
early 30s i'm like hey you know what you
know after my contract was up my one
year said i'd take some time off travel
around asia because it was
you know early 2000s it was a nice time
and jp morgan needed somebody
that understood futures in singapore
beyond
fixed income right so with my experience
in commodities
and elsewhere i joined j.p morgan i was
vice president of futures trading at
jpmorgan in singapore i spent
eight years there okay so and that's a
trading
desk right i'm not sitting in an office
looking at numbers and spreadsheets and
things like that no you know i'm there
on the
um you know on the native systems
trading away
okay for eight years i'd come in at five
in the morning which is
sorry six in the morning when globex
reopened at five pm chicago time and i
would be there
until about um 5 pm in the afternoon you
know after
getting burned out for doing that for
eight years
12 hours a day i said i i need i think
i'm going to kill myself i have a heart
attack
so i left and i started trading for
myself
then a few years later i started you
know i started writing my book and then
from my book became the order flows
company right and it's a software runs
on ninjatrader eight
and it's our third version of it right
and the reason i created this software
is because i was
trading for myself i was using order
flow but
the software that was out there was just
very basic very limited
right and there's still people selling
the same software that they were selling
you know in 2013 2015 with very little
improvements
you know maybe they put an extra drawing
tool or something on it but you know
there's certain ways i use the order
flow right certain things i'm always
looking for i said why can't i just take
what i'm looking for
have the software show it to me
right so i don't have to sit here and
try and decide is this or is this not
right that's the power of computers and
the reason i talk about this is because
you know the charts you see in this
presentation are generated from
the software right then this is what i
talk about when i say
make trading easier right don't don't
make it harder that you got to learn all
this stuff but the software
show it to you okay and
again you know once you see how easy
and quickly you can apply order flow to
your trading
you can become a better trader right you
know imagine you know like having
you know a professional trader sitting
next to you telling you oh you know this
is what's happening in the market that's
what's happening in the market
all right so you know just before we
dive in here you know a brief disclaimer
this you know trading involves risk
don't
trade with money you can't afford to
lose basically we all know that so
when you ever look at a bar chart do you
ever really stop and think
where that information comes from right
i mean yeah we could see well
you know i can see the market selling
off but all you're looking at is the
open high low close
well yeah that's just basic information
it comes from the time and sales right
every time there's a trade
goes through that it's time stamped with
a time
and you know the price and the quantity
all right
and now you know people like to look at
the depth of market the trading dome
you know the price ladder so you can see
where the bids are where the offers are
okay you know but the problem with time
and sales
the problem with the depth of market the
price ladder is
they move super fast and it's hard for
a lot of traders especially um traders
new to trying to understand order flow
to make heads or tails of what's
happening you know if you've ever been
to
you know watch formula one or watch you
know the blue angels flying in the sky
trying to take a picture of a car going
200 miles an hour or
you know a jet you know flying in the in
the sky trying to take a picture or
something it's very difficult right
so trying to look at time and sales and
trying to look at the price ladder
sometimes is very difficult because it's
moving so fast right you want to take
that information
and put it into a format that's easy to
read
so the difference between time and sales
in a bar chart
remember time and sales you know shows
the price that traded it shows the time
it shows the volume bar chart just shows
the price they're traded
right at least time and sales shows the
price traded and the volume
right and more importantly it shows the
side of the market it traded on whether
it traded on the bid
or traded on the offer all right and
that's very important information that
any trader wants to know
you know back in the days when there was
a trading floor
and a big local started buying everybody
would follow him
you know or you know a goldman sachs
would come in with a big order to sell
you know 2 000 e-minis right the locals
would follow him right because
why it's because they know that that
volume is affecting the market and
that's where order flow comes in if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
you're not seeing that information
so you know order flow right a normal
bar chart how most traders view the
market is
on a normal bar chart they say well you
know the price opened up at 39 and a
half traded down to 38 and three
quarters
and we closed at 39 and a quarter so
it's a red candle
you know down a tick but order flow
traders
see the exact same bar and you know they
see
okay well we opened at 39 and a half we
traded down
you know volume is in the middle the
point of control for the bar is more or
less in the middle
we traded down to eight and three
quarters but very little traded then we
started coming back
up and there was aggressive buying right
there's so much more information you can
take away
from the same bar from the same
information
and the the interesting thing is that
people
sort of overlook is you can get this
information
from your normal level one you don't
need level two like you would if you're
looking at the depth of market price
ladder
right level one information gives it to
you because you're getting the time and
sales
it's whether you choose to look at it on
a normal bar chart
or on an order flow footprint chart so
again you know understand
where the chart comes from right it's
easy to just look at a chart
and you know after the fact and said oh
yeah you know that would have been a
good buy here or there
well after the fact but as it's trading
that's when you want to make those
decisions
right so from the time in sales from the
dome the depth of market the information
you see on your bar chart
comes from what's traded in the market
right from what you see in that time in
sales
again they leave out the most important
piece of information the volume that's
traded on the bid
the volume that's traded on the offer so
this is yesterday
right in the e-minis you know we had
sold off and we're just sort of going
sideways
right and again you know people are
wondering you know are we going to come
down and make
a new low or are we going to start
rallying from here right i mean
in a sideways market you don't really
want to be
trading that unless there's something
actionable for you
right you know people like to draw
you'll have moving averages have v
web but everything is flat at this time
in terms of view app in terms of moving
averages or whatever a lot of their your
indicators
are just showing up as you know it's
flat lining going across here
now order flow traders have that
advantage because
they are seeing what's actually trading
in the market
right the volumes trading on the bid the
volumes traded on the offer
you know is there net aggressive buying
or is there net aggressive selling
right and again this footprint here
on this chart is this right here
and again it's easy after the market
rallies from 41 18 and a half
all the way up to 23 and a half to say
yeah that would have been a good buy
but when you're looking at it right when
you're looking at
a chart right this is the period before
it rallied
right you can't make heads or tails out
of that like yeah i don't know is it
going to rally you know you got big
wicks to the upside big wicks to the
downside
it's really you know a market that's not
really going anywhere but by looking at
the order flow you start to see that
information that's telling you
the direction the market's going in
right
and again if you're just looking at that
bar chart after the fact it's easy
all right but you don't trade after the
fact you got to trade now in real time
right so take it a step further right
when i say you know let the computer do
the work for you let the software
highlight areas where there's instances
in the order flow
that's actionable right that's bullish
or bearish right show you where buyers
are getting uh stronger or weaker show
you areas where the market is
potentially reversing and so much more
and
you can see it in here you know if you
have software that highlights it to you
i mean you could sort of pick it up
yourself if you spend enough time
looking at a chart but yeah i honestly i
know a lot of people are impatient right
that's the beauty of having software
that's going to highlight it to you you
know you see these little
green um points of controls here and
here
these are telling you there's bullish
order flow in the market
right and you see how the market rallies
up from there right from these levels
right so it's telling you there's some
nice buying opportunity
now right rather than after the market
makes that move up right again you know
this is
mini nasdaq yesterday okay what
what's gonna happen next right we're
selling off we made a new low then we're
just sort of drifting down sideways
right
you know you got some you got a little
doji bar here a little doji bar here
you're trying to make heads or tails of
you know are we going to take out this
low
you know we're only you know
a point and a half away from this low
you know why can't we take it out if
just a little bit more selling comes in
could easily break that low but if
you're looking at an order flow chart
you can understand
what's going on right you can see that
you know as we came back down to this
low even though you're getting a couple
inside bars here
the net buying right the deltas are nice
positive deltas
right you have very tight bars but very
strong buying going on
in this little bar here in this other
bar
right here right then obviously this
next bar
very big aggressive buying as the bar
gets stretched out you got a lot of
buying and balances which i'll talk
about later
and the market rallies you know it
rallies about 30 points
so again you know if you really want to
make your trading easier
have software that takes like the
information from the time and sales from
the depth of market
and put it into an easy to read format
right
and as you can see here right you're
seeing
again the green point of control which
telling you is bullish right you're
seeing
this value area which i'll talk about
later as being
blue which is also very bullish right
so you're seeing a lot of things and if
you know how to understand what's
happening in the delta it's also very
bullish
so you're at the practically at the low
of the day
and a lot of bullish information is
coming into the market
right so that that is actionable
information right
you can take a very low risk trade you
see you see this bar come in oh i got
a lot of bullish things happening in
this bar yeah i'll get long
i could have a tight stop you know what
a tight stop is considered now in the
nasdaq
but you know if we're wrong you're going
to know right away if we're wrong
if all this bullish information all this
bullish order flow
is wrong the market's going to correct
and start trading into it
right and get to the other side you know
you're wrong you don't have to have a
stop below the low of the day
you can have your stop you know below
sort of this value of this bar because
if we
come back in we take out these bullish
things in the order flow
then it's not bullish right okay it's
the market just popped in some bullish
information but then the market reversed
you know so you can have a very tight
stop rather than trying to buy you know
way up here with a stop way down here
you can have a tight stop you know
imagine trading nasdaq with
you know relatively tight stops you know
it's unheard of
and this is a 30-second chart
but again you know this is that same
chart this is that low right here right
we went up from
you know the 30 35 area all the way up
to
90 95 right almost you know straight up
yeah we'll pull back here but then
continue back up
but again you know imagine you just
caught this move here from
40 up to 70 right
you're happy so
again you know a bar chart just shows
the price that traded but that's just
the starting point
an order flow chart shows the price
traded and the volume traded but more
importantly the volume traded on the bid
and the volume traded on the offer
so again knowing what trades on the bid
in the offer is going to help you
because you're going to
understand the direction of the market
right through the aggressive
um the aggression so what that means is
you know the markets trade in a two-way
auction
right there's a bid which is the buyers
and there's an offer
which are the sellers now these are
passive traders they're passive buyers
they're passive sellers
for a trade to happen a trader needs to
either buy the offer
or a trader needs to sell the bid so
they have to cross that bid offer line
and when a trader does that he is
considered the aggressor
right and you know you call them
aggressive traders right and that's the
information that you're going to see
in the footprint in here white like why
this number is blue
as opposed to black if it's black inside
the bar
that's just your normal order flow but
when you see eight traded against 61
it's telling you you had aggressive
buying
right so that that's what things that's
one of the more important things that
you're going to be looking for
is where the aggressive buying is coming
and you know at what price levels so
again back in the old days i mean i
think the nicest is the only one that
still has a trading floor
you know back when the cme had a floor
board of trade had a floor
you know people exchange memberships
were selling for
close to a million dollars because that
the traders on the floor had access to
that information they could see
the buying and the selling that was
going on they were right there
in the pit right so they could see the
big orders coming into the market and
being able to trade off that as opposed
to someone sitting in an office
just looking at price on the screen
that's one of the reasons
why exchange memberships were so much is
they had
access to information that other people
just didn't
right now time and sales right it gives
you
a lot of information you probably never
really wondered why it's different
colors
but there's a reason right
if it is well in this case it's orange
but you know you can change the colors
to whatever
blue and red i have it oranges and green
but all this trading that's orange color
is an aggressive seller came in and sold
these prices for this quantity right now
you know the exchange separates it by
order size so there's a lot of one lots
and stuff you see
then the market you can see went from
36 38 86 and a half offered a
50 to bid you know because there's
trading going on
right at this time here it's currently
trading 86 and a quarter at 86 and a
half
okay so the problem is if you're trying
to if you watch time and sales during
the day in real time it moves super fast
you're not gonna be able to
by the time you notice something it's
gone right the opportunity
is gone but you can take that
information you can put it in a
footprint chart
so you could make heads or tails so you
can see oh you know what i had
imbalances selling imbalances going on
here i had aggressive selling happening
here
right but if you're looking on here it's
just gone it's oh yeah
all red all red all red etc but
when you take that and you put it on a
footprint chart it gives you a chance to
understand it right and that's really
the whole point of looking at a
footprint chart
now once you have a footprint chart you
got to realize
there's what is sort of the basic
information you're going to look at
right well there's three there's delta
there's point of control and there's
imbalances
delta is the difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
in the bar
all right and that's important i'll talk
about that in a minute when it controls
the price level in the bar
with the most volume okay and that's
important right all these are important
that's why i'm talking about them
imbalances are when aggressive buyers
outnumber aggressive sellers
by four to one or more and vice versa
when aggressive
sellers outnumber aggressive buyers by
four to one now again you know that four
to one is
sort of the industry standard if there
was an industry standard but it's what
most traders
use and again you could adjust it if you
want to use three to one
if you want to use ten to one right you
know different people different strokes
for different folks
in terms of imbalances so delta will
normally appear at the bottom of a chart
i mean some software like to put it up
above and below the bar because they
don't want to
take your eye off the bar you know i
guess they think you can't chew
walk and chew gum at the same time but
you can see generally as the market is
selling off delta
in each bar is negative because
aggressive sellers are in control
not always but generally then as markets
rallies markets are going up as prices
going up
you have generally aggressive buyers
right because you have buyers in control
of the market
now point of control every bar has a
point of control just as every bar has
an imbalance i'll show you as every bar
has a delta
now the delta is sorry the point of
control rather is the price level in the
bar
with the most volume period what was
traded on the bid what was traded on the
offer
at that price not in the two-way auction
just at that price
okay so you see every bar i have some
highlighted here
now the thing is
every bar has a point of control but not
every bar's point of control
matters right i've shown you those
examples earlier where the market
rallied based off of where the point of
control appeared in a bar
because in our studies we have found
that
depending on the type of bar what's
happening in the bar
relative to the previous bars where the
point of control comes in it could be
signaling something bullish or bearish
happening in the market
okay and you know for example right if
you have point of control if you have a
lot
of the volume towards the bottom of the
bar and we can't really trade below it
then the market rallies well you know
you've got support just as if you had
you know a point of control up near the
high of the bar
and we can't really get past it you know
a lot of volume is going through there
you know it could be telling you there's
resistance right you know that's just
sort of a
basic basic framework but you know you
start to
understand what's happening in the
market based on the delta
based on the point of control based on
imbalances now
imbalances where there's buying
imbalances and they're selling the
balances right
so you're going to look for buying
imbalances on moves up selling and
balances on moves down
and in the footprint it's going to be
blue for buying and balance
or red for selling a balance and it's a
good sign
um you know for knowing
the direction of the market you know
sometimes you know markets sort of going
sideways but then you see all of a
sudden you see a bar come in with a lot
of buying imbalances
well that's good it's telling you
there's a lot of aggressive buying
happening
in the bar then you pair it together
with the delta
you know and it gives you a good clue as
to
where the market is going so just really
briefly
buying and balances selling and balances
okay we'll talk about buying balances
first
right they're the blue numbers in the
footprint so you can see six against 30
7 against 35
15 against 80 2 against 15 6 against 27
these are imbalances because the
difference is greater than four to one
it's you know two against 15 is
you know that's greater than four to one
um 15 against 80 is greater than four to
one
right but it's happening on the offer
side so you have aggressive buyers
buying the offer
right and you can see as the markets
move up you see a lot of bars with
buying imbalances all right
now there's a thing a lot of order flow
traders understand
imbalances and they understand the next
step which is a stacked imbalance right
where you have
um you know three or more imbalances
stacked neatly nice
pretty on top of each other one two
three four
five six in this case all stacked neatly
on top of each other there could be a
stop that
got triggered could be somebody that
swept through the markets okay
but the important thing to take away is
there's a lot of aggressive buying
happening in a short burst
okay so selling it balances is sort of
the opposite right it's red colors
in the footprint so four against
eighteen zero against twenty seven five
against twenty seven
you know three against nineteen six
against forty two in the two-way auction
when the market was bid and offered
there was more aggressive selling
to the bid than aggressive buying from
the offer
that's a selling imbalance right and as
you can see as the markets move down you
see the selling imbalances
now you also have stacked selling
imbalances right just as you have
stacked buying and balances
and that's when you have three or more
imbalances stacked neatly on top of each
other
one two three kicks off a nice selling
imbalance which you know people use
these as support as
resistance level in the near term okay
so you can see here you got stack
selling and balance
market traded back up in here you're
looking for that selling
to reappear and if the selling and
balance holds the stack selling and
balance holds you look for the market to
sell off which it did so
having all that order flow information
is nice right but
you gotta know how to take it and
use it right i mean you can see how the
market traded
but you to know how you could use that
information
to take trades right that's the whole
point of order flow
now you got to understand there's
different market conditions
right it's it's not always markets go up
right as a lot of
people think this past year you know
everything goes up stocks never go down
but they don't really think about these
market conditions they think of terms of
trending markets or consolidating
markets okay so in other words
a driven market is a trending market a
rotating market is a consolidating
market and
you know depending on the conditions
that you're trading in is going to
determine how you trade
right you might you can't trade a
trending market the same way you trade a
consolidating market
because it takes two different trading
styles right because they're two
different market conditions just as
um you know you're not going to
drive the same way when it's snowing as
opposed to
when it's hot and dry and sunny outside
right so
you got to understand that and sometimes
people don't they just think well
there's a signal i got to take it
right you always got to be trading in
context of the market
so what's the difference between a flow
driven market and a rotating market
well in a rotating market it's just the
usual suspects right the retail traders
um you know and people just happy to
facilitate trade
you know the market's not moving because
you know one there's probably no
um nothing no driver in the market to
to move price in a direction you know
the big players
are absent basically and so it's just
left
up to you know all the little people the
usual suspects so to speak
to trade now in a flow driven market
it's completely different
right it's the big institutional traders
that are trading right they're the ones
that
are moving the market and you still have
the usual suspects right the the
everybody else trading but the big
traders are active
in a flow-driven market okay
and after all what causes the market to
go up or down
right it's the aggressive traders right
if everyone's just happy to sit on a bid
and sit on the offer market's not going
to move
you need somebody to say you know what i
got money i think the market's going to
move
i'm going to buy you know a thousand
contracts right that's in
you're just gonna buy it with impunity
right buy the offer
buy the next offer buy the next offer
that's the aggressive trader right
that's how markets move
but again how can you see the aggressive
trading on a bar chart you can't
right it appears on a time and sales but
again who wants to look at
time and sales right the easiest way to
look for imbalances
is sorry the easiest way to look for a
flow driven market is in
imbalances and delta in the footprint
chart
now in a normal rotating market the
order flow is normal
you don't see a whole heck of a lot of
imbalances or anything really special
volume wise right but in a flow driven
market you see the clues
that the big traders are active and
moving the market so you know just for
example
this is normal market activity right
we're in a tight range
you see both buying and selling
imbalances you know people say well you
saw you said
if you know flow driven market you see
buying imbalances you see selling
balances yeah you see them on one side
here it's mixed right you see
a bar with selling imbalances and a bar
with mine imbalances the same bar
right it's just telling you it's a quiet
market right now if
you know you're seeing long bars right
when you start seeing long bars you've
got to understand
volatility is picking up as to a market
like this this is low volatility
really what is volatility is the market
searching for price right searching for
volume that's why you have bars being
stretched out
again normal market activity right it's
just going sideways
you know a whole lot of nothing going on
small delta is pretty evenly matched
eight seven it tell me it's traded 2
000 contracts and the net difference
between buyers and sellers is
eight eight right
there's nothing going on right but
that's just normal market activity
the market exists to facilitate trade to
match buyers with sellers now a flow
driven market
you see things completely different you
see big delta numbers in a direction
right you see
you know minus 700 minus 2 000 minus
1400 minus 800
you're seeing a lot of imbalances in a
bar you know
here you're seeing selling imbalances
selling imbalances selling imbalances
selling imbalances
right you're not seeing a whole heck of
a lot of buying and balance sure there's
a couple
you know mixed in but mostly what you're
seeing is aggressive selling
right here's the market was rallying
here all right this is
this is this morning right in the crude
right we made that low at 86.
but you're seeing you know relatively
small deltas and you've seen the
aggressive buying come in here multiple
buying imbalances right you're seeing
things in the
order flow here that's giving you
bullish signs right with the
um the points of controls with the value
area which i'll talk about these later
right because these are very important
aspects of order flow
right it's crude oil yesterday right big
sell-off right i mean it's just people
selling here with impunity right
minus 600 you've seen a lot of selling
imbalances
right you're seeing stack selling
imbalances minus 600 minus 1400 in the
delta
right it's not really pausing it's just
big traders coming in selling it right
they they want to be short or if they
have supply they just want to get rid of
it
right that's a difference between a flow
driven market and
a normal market right is the the type of
trading that's happening
and the easiest way to tell is obviously
imbalances
and secondly is deltas what are deltas
doing
right you got a bar here so you know and
look at these right internal delta
numbers max and min delta is just really
quick it's interesting
it's very tiny 0 17
7 0 0 at no point was aggressive buying
you know these bars with zero max delta
ever in control
never all right so let's talk about some
setups here
okay i mean this is the interesting part
of where you could start putting these
things together
you know one of my favorite movies was
was karate kid right i love the new
cobra kai series you know sweep the leg
johnny
because it's um you know it's a saying
that we used to use on the trading desk
when the feature was introduced to us
back in the in the 90s on on comex right
they had a sweep function
so you know you're trading the metals
and energies you can sweep the market up
through
or down through certain prices so a
market sweep occurs when a trader takes
out
several price levels in one trade so
this is the market right it's currently
25 bid 41 25 and a quarter offer
right but you know i'm a big buyer i
think the market's going to go up
you know i've got 500 to buy a thousand
to buy
i look at the depth of the market okay
well there's not much on the offer
sure i gotta buy 500. so you know i can
try and piece it in
but you know my buying might trigger off
other buying you know other people will
see oh there's a buyer trying to finesse
the market and they jump in
so what do i do right and i've done this
many many times
you know throughout my career is okay i
know i got
500 to buy but there's only about 300 up
to 26.
i'll just put in my order 4126 to buy
300.
okay it's going to leave me 200 left
over but
you know i'm happy to buy that because i
know that my buying is probably going to
trigger off
people that are watching the dome
thinking oh you know price just
skipped you know price jumped i gotta
start buying the
six and a quarters to six and a half
because now
you know i've bought 300 up to 26 and if
i put the whole size in by 500 up to 26
the market is now 26 bid right it's 26
bid at 26 and a quarter
i cleared out all these offers here
right next to then the bids will start
filling in down here
okay so a cell sweep is the opposite
right so you know if it's 25 25 and a
quarter
and i've got a thousand to sell i could
look at the book i could see gosh you
know i can only sell about
you know 700 down to 24 that's going to
leave me with 300
okay i'll sell it down to 24. okay so
now the market is
oh i got this backwards it's uh 24 offer
and 23 and three quarters bid right
because i've turned it offered here so
it's now three
three quarters bid offered f4 i wrote
this backwards but um
and then i'm because i'm still working
my balance there i swept it through
so what are some of the signs in the
order flow is there's not much counter
trade that happens right because as i'm
sweeping it's going through in one trade
very fast and i mean there's still trade
going on so you know you might see one
or two contracts trade on the offer
that's sort of in flight as my sweep is
going through
so for a sweep to effectively
move the market right again
sweep is going to more effectively move
a market that's got less liquidity
meaning less bids or offers that you're
trying to sweep through
now if someone is working an iceberg
here you know maybe someone's got a
thousand to sell at five and a half and
is only showing
50 you know and i try to buy 500 up to
26 i'll be filled on everything
up to 50 and it's still going to be now
25 and a quarter
at five and a half because that iceberg
is still there that i don't see what the
iceberg is
until i until i trade against it
basically
now again you know when a sweep runs
into an iceberg you don't know where the
icebergs are because the exchanges don't
put that information out unless you
trade against it then you can see you
know the
ton number the ticket order number
there's a certain designation for
icebergs
but again if you're watching a dome you
can sort of pick it now on a normal
candlestick chart you can't see a sweep
going on
right you don't know when there's big
aggressive buying you say well there's a
big bar here it must be strong
aggressive mine yeah but you don't see
where the sweep is coming in
right on a footprint chart if you know
what to look for
yes you can see it right and it it's
this is really in my opinion one of the
beauty things of order flow is
being able to see these the sweeping
activity that
other traders can't right and again
you know if you were to sweep it up to
and a half basically you're going from
this depth of market
to this right before it was 25 25 and a
quarter
now it's gone six bit at six and a
okay then the the volumes just
automatically fill in the algos will
fill it in for you
but if you're looking at the footprint
and you know what to look for you can
see yeah there's a sweep here yes there
was a sweep here
yes there was a sweep here okay but
again
let the software analyze it for you you
know you could go
drive yourself crazy trying to figure
this stuff out is this a sweep is this
not a sweep
have software do it for you right and
that's you know my software
the order flows trader software we have
a thing called sweep detector so we can
see
this activity when it's happening as
opposed to
trading on a hunch yeah i think there
was a sweep there but i'm not sure you
know we've sort of defined the rules for
it right and you can even adjust the
rules
on a normal chart this is a five minute
chart okay
you can't tell you can see well yeah
there was some strong selling here right
obviously there's there's big aggressive
selling because you got the big down bar
okay on a bar on a footprint chart
right you can see well yeah i have some
imbalances here so obviously that's
that's bearish
right okay you know in fact that's a
stacked selling imbalance
right most traders order full traders
look at stacks selling the balances and
they trade around them which is good
but if you're looking at sweeps you can
see there was a sweep that happened
up here much earlier than this big down
candle right where would you rather be
short up here at 95
we're down here at 80. right that's an
extra 15
ticks that you can get as a trader
right and then the market sells off
sells off starts working its way back up
we got a bullish sweep right here i mean
we still have some sweeps down here as
we're going down but
you should already been short from well
up here but now you're seeing something
bullish in the order flow
and the market starts rallying right
from 60
all the way up to 80. now
that sweeps now the next thing i want to
talk about is order flow sequencing
okay and
you know this is one of the new features
that we put in the software last year
and what it is is when there's resting
liquidity is stacked and taken out so
what is stacked mean
well each subsequent bid on the downside
is bigger than
the bid above it so you can see here
like 96 121
153 200 241 289
right or every subsequent offer is
bigger right you see 21 75 89
113 but then you have a gap it just goes
back down to 62 so you got an area of
very little liquidity then 153 199
so i'd consider this stacked these four
prices
stacked but the then stack starts up
again
right so the book is not always stacked
like that right but when it
is right is
watching how it trades when it trades
okay so
show you right on the footprint chart
you'd have to look at
how it traded right and it's it's hard
to to look at
a footprint chart and you know uh you
know trying to you know look and sort of
get the sequence in your head right but
there's sequencing right and you're not
going to look at sequencing on both the
bid and
and the offer side all the time there's
going to look at it in certain spots
but trying to look at it can be
could make you blind you know trying to
make all the stuff it's going to give
you a lot of extra work let the order
flow do it for you can see sequencing
bullish sequencing bullish sequencing
this is the cash open here boiler
sequencing
swing high bearish sequencing at the
swing high
market sells off i mean look at the
right before the next big bar
down right more bearish sequencing
market keeps going down that's a five
minute chart in the e-minis
right let software show it to you right
here you can see sequencing you can
adjust the cluster size
and you know how you want it to show up
on the chart this is crude oil
bullish sequencing as the market's going
up bearish
sequencing market starts going down
bullish sequencing market starts going
back up
mini nasdaq 30 20 range chart bearish
sequencing
boom market sells off you start seeing
the bullish sequencing
the market is eating through subsequent
higher offer volumes
right that's important to know as a
trader that the volumes are
heavy solid but the market is just
eating right
through it right as it's making its move
back up
and 20 range chart i don't put the
arrows here but you can see
sequencing bullish bullish sequencing
boiler sequencing
bearish sequencing followed by bullish
bullish bullish bullish bullish
it's the swing high no sequencing on the
swing high but the bar
right after it bearish sequencing as we
drop from
you know the mid 60s all the way down to
the mid 40s
again now this is apple right people
always ask about well i trade stocks
what can i do for stocks
okay well this is apple stock right
right here right off the low of the day
yesterday bullish sequencing all right
market rallied went up made a new high
right up here 153 53 started going
sideways
okay what's going to happen we're going
sideways we've got two inside bars
but in the second inside bar you see
bearish sequencing
okay i'm you know at this point i'm
thinking well
maybe this market's got some capacity to
go down next bar lower
than the next bar another inside bar but
with bearish
sequencing and what happens boom
finally the market reacted to it this
is jp morgan
my favorite um right off the low the day
yesterday
two o'clock straight up that's a nice 45
degree line
straight up bullish sequencing off the
low
okay now the thing with order flows i
get this question a lot and i sort of
want to touch it right this is tesla
this is a 30 second chart for example
if you're going to use order flow on
stocks there really have to be stocks
that trade
like jpmorgan or apple you know stocks
that have
a lot of volume at every price increment
you know
on stocks that sort of jump around it's
not going to be very effective right
honestly it's hard to make heads or
tails of some of the stuff because
every price is going to be an imbalance
because it's against zero because the
price is too
erratic and you don't have volume at
every single price
um increment right like you do let's say
jpmorgan or
you do at apple okay so just bear that
in mind um
you know when you're using order flow
right it because you're analyzing volume
so there needs to be volume at
price right if it skips around a lot
it's just not going to be very effective
now the tools to make order flow trading
easier
right so you know i've talked about the
order flows trader at the beginning
because i want you to see how easy it is
to read order flow in the market
right it's going to help you see who's
in control of the market to be in sync
with the market
understand why the market stops and
reverses you know and many other things
but you should always be asking you know
what more can the software do for you
right and that's why i created the order
flows trader software you know when i
first released it in 2015
there was like four four indicators in
there right we still have them you know
we've expanded them over the years as
you know we are able to you know when
ninjatrader 8 came out there was you
know it really opened up
like a pandora's toolbox so to speak for
us
on what we can do without overwhelming
the system
and you know so we can see where market
exhaustion exists where market weakness
is
support and resistance based on what's
trading right now
not based on pivot levels or trend lines
no it's based on the actual volumes that
are going through
sweeping activity which i just showed
you market imbalance i talked about
imbalances i'm going to show you
something else with imbalances which is
amazing show you the value right the
value areas
in a bar you know where the aggressive
trading is coming in and much more
so market exhaustion right now again
this was one of the original
tools in 2015 that you know a lot of
traders say it really
changed their trading and they developed
trading plans right around it
is we're showing you in a bar right you
see these
green lines here it's telling you
there's price
there's basically market exhaustion
right at the lows
here here based on the order flow okay
and generally as markets move up you're
going to see price exhaustion coming in
you know on the moves up right meaning
there's price exhaustion
below this bar right people aren't
interested in trading
below this price level you know and
that's how you know moves are over right
when nobody's interested to sell anymore
that's how you know moves down are over
when there's no more sellers
just as moves higher are over when
there's no more buyers when people
aren't interested in buying anymore
the market is just going to naturally
sell off
right i don't think it's selling off but
you have no more buyers
right so there's just nothing to move
the market higher anymore
that was an e-mini one-minute chart but
this work is fascinating right
10 years 10 years trade
very massive volumes you know 10 years
is probably one of the
more liquid most liquid contracts in
terms of liquidity in the market because
it trades thousands
and thousands at a price level before it
moves
but if you can see market exhaustion
right it's telling you buyers aren't
interested
above this price level okay what can you
do with that as a trader well you could
get short
right or sellers aren't interested below
this level what can you do
you can get long and again you know the
beauty of 10 years
i don't recommend it unless you have a
lot of money but it's since it's such a
liquid contract
right you could trade big size in that
and
if you could catch a move in it i know
guys that trade hundreds 100 lots in
the 10 years because they're only
looking for
two ticks three ticks and that's where a
tool like
knowing there's market exhaustion coming
in on such a liquid contract
right that you can get your two ticks
three ticks
three ticks three ticks consistently
i mean there's gonna be times like this
where started going up then it came back
down
right then made the move but you know as
a trader that's that's what trading is
about
right trading around these levels
now market weakness is another piece of
information
that a trader can have and it shows up
in the order flow now there's two types
of market weakness
you know when people think of market
weakness they don't think in terms of
bullish and bearish okay
but bearish market weakness occurs when
the market has been moving
higher but can't sustain the move higher
the buying is weakening
okay whereas on um
bullish market weakness right sounds you
know you don't think of
a bullish market as having weakness but
what that means is
a market has been going lower and lower
but finally the selling
just tapers off there's no more selling
the selling is exhausted
the selling weakened okay and you see
this
day in and day out in all the markets so
bullish market weakness
market's been going down down down down
but the sellers are getting less and
less until the buyers take control of
the market the selling is weakening
you can watch the delta right you can
see what's happening in the delta
because
delta is going to be strong but then not
so strong
and not so strong then it's going to
flip and turn the other way direction
bearish market weakness the market has
been going up up up up but the buying is
weakening until there's no more strong
buyers
the market's not going to keep going up
forever unless you have buyers but if
the buyers are
dropping off you know if everyone is
bought who's going to move the market
higher nobody
again watch the delta is aggressive
buying getting stronger or weaker as the
market is still going up
so here's an example right mark is just
it got a swing high here
just sort of going sideways but if
you're watching the delta it's kind of
mixed 355 137
400 414 313 27
obviously it turns negative here 300.
this orange arrow is telling you there's
market weakness happening in the market
right because where's your buyers were
you just up here at your swing high
you know the low of the day was here
rally up swing high
but there's just no more buying it's
just gotten weaker it's gone you know
it's still
negative then it's positive smaller
positive smaller positive turns negative
boom sells off into new lows this is the
bullish market weakness right you're
selling off right you're selling off
generally you have
nice strong deltas 58 then just minus
three gotten weak
75 okay that's strong but then it gets
weaker again
42 39 you got a bullish prominent point
of control here
and the market starts rallying right
this is your signal that there's
bullish market weakness right and that's
what the software does it shows you
these things
now i talked about imbalances earlier
because you know one of my favorite
trading
methods is trading multiple imbalances
and it's really like this right it's
picking out these little things
you know when everything looks the same
but picking out these little
instances in the market now i talked
about stacked imbalances right you have
a stacked imbalance here but the market
went nowhere
okay then we came off made a new low and
then we rallied off this low this is
yesterday
that 10 and a half low all right we
rallied back up
you have a bar with one two three four
five
six imbalances now there's no stacked
imbalance like you have up here
because they're spread out in the bar
and what the software will do it will
highlight the bar it'll put this
magenta box you could change it around
the bar that has multiple buying
imbalances
a green bar that has multiple buying and
balances or a red bar
it has multiple selling imbalances right
so
as you're going down into the lows yeah
that's nice to see
selling multiple sauna balances that's
what you expect to see right you're
making new lows you expect to see the
aggressive
sellers come in but you're at the low of
the day now you have aggressive buyers
coming in
and if you're just looking for stacked
imbalances you don't notice it
not at all because they're not stacked
there's you got
six imbalances but they're spread out in
the bar and the market
rallied from that bar with multiple
imbalances again
the software is highlighting it to me
we're going up and making new highs
right in the e-minis here right you got
on the way up you take out the high you
got stacked buying a balance that's what
you expect to see you expect to see
buying and balances going up into the
highs
but you hit that new high 78 and a half
and then what do you see aggressive
selling
multiple selling and bounces one two
three four selling imbalances
they're not stacked so if you're looking
for stacked imbalances
you're not even noticing what's
happening in this bar
you have three inbound uh four
imbalances and you know the market
put in a nice little drop
okay so that's you know sort of the
power of looking at multiple imbalances
and having software that's going to
highlight to you
where multiple imbalances are now value
area
if you've ever studied market profile
you understand what value area is
right and you know there's a value very
high is the value area low
which is different than the high the bar
and the low of the bar it's worth 70
percent of the volume trades
for the day right the on the market
profile looking at the value areas
but you can take a step further you can
look at it on a bar by bar basis
okay so you can see every bar still has
its point of control you still got your
normal footprint you still got your
buying and balance and sound and
balances
but now there's a bigger rectangle
that's the value
area okay every bar is going to have a
value area but again not every value
area is going to matter
and where it gets interesting is you can
see how value is developing sideways
right and then it gaps between this bar
and this bar
value develops sideways it gaps lower
right there's als
there's a whole new form of analysis you
can make
but what we've found over the years
in in our using it is there are certain
value areas
that matter like i said every bar is
gonna have a value area
but there's certain ones that are gonna
be bullish or bearish and you can see
here
it's colored red if it's bearish right
if it's blue
it would be bullish right so you can see
bearish value area
what happens market sells off right but
every bar has a value area
it's how you connect the dots in this
case we're letting the software
based on you know our method of
order flow analysis on how
a value area is bullish or bearish
highlight it to us right i mean there's
still other forms of analysis we can do
with the value areas but having that
as a quick heads up say oh you know what
this one's bearish
okay i got to look for continuation
just as this is nasdaq a bullish value
area you know this might be a little
hard to see on your screen but this is
blue right whereas the other ones are
gray
right right as the market is getting
ready to
rally about 20 points right you're sort
of going sideways and puts in a nice
bullish value area right and again a
value area is just
the area where 70 percent of the volume
now you could adjust it people like to
use 68
other people use different numbers you
know they
like to fine tune it but 70 is you know
one standard deviation more or less
and that's important so when you have a
bullish value area
generally you're looking for the market
to rally right just as
if you have a bearish one okay and and
really that's you know
a lot of the power of the order flow
comes from taking the information that
you're seeing
and feeding it into the computer and
have the computer say you know what yeah
this is bullish this is bearish based on
a set
criteria right so you don't have to sit
here scratching your head
is that bullish is that bearish well you
know at a glance right
now you take it a step further and add
in your other you know your
other forms of analysis whether you're
using technical analysis or
or order flow there's so much more you
could build off of it
right so
you can see right there's just so much
much more information available
from the order flow than traders
realized right unfortunately there's not
enough time to discuss it today i've
been going on for about an hour
so remember don't just trade the market
blindly trade in context of the market
at all times right
you want to be buying by the dips so to
speak you know
sell the rallies but if the order flow
tells you there's something
bearish coming into the market after the
market rallies or something bullish
coming into the market
after the market has sold off right
that's what context is all about
now remember right a plain footprint
chart already has a lot of information
you could
people just trade a footprint chart like
this naked all day long
right and that's fine you can do that
but what i'm saying is
why don't you let software
show you help you show you market
weakness support resistance level
sweeping activity market imbalances
you know value aggressive trading and
all the other
benefits of using order flow i mean it
to me just makes perfect sense
you know why try to swim upstream you
know swim with the current of the market
and again you know order flow
is really about understanding what the
aggressive traders are doing in the
market
take this information on the time and
sales
put it into your brain but not in such a
way that you can't understand it
you know process that information don't
make trading more difficult
than it needs to be right again you know
people like to complicate things i'm
saying keep it as simple as possible
so in my opinion there's always two ways
to do things right there's the easy way
there's the hard way
i prefer the easy way i've been down the
hard way
in the past and it's difficult right
you're going to struggle
i prefer the path of least resistance i
let the computer show me
what's happening right now in the market
right so this past hour hopefully you
agree it's been time well spent
but again i can't cover everything in a
60-minute training session
you know every week i do a live group
training for users of the software
where i go through you know interesting
things in the order flow
how to use the software you know
settings i go
talk about you know how you can use this
setting for a particular market let you
ask questions
but i can't do it like on a session like
today okay
but i've got a special offer for you so
you can get everything you need to know
about order flow
and if you act fast i'll give you a very
very special deal now when i say special
deal
because i know price is going to go up
soon okay i've been saying that i've
been a little bit reluctant to
to raise it my programmer suggested that
we
raise it and you know quite a few users
saying you know your software you should
raise the price
but you know i like to keep software
affordable
to to traders because you know order
flow is theirs for everybody to use
so you can be thrilled right i got the
order flows trader
for ninjatrader eights now
it works on ninjatrader eight because
you know i'm a futures guy i trade
futures
and it just makes sense you know it's an
easy platform
um for most people to use and that's
what i've been using when when i first
programmed had the software programmed
okay
now it's the volume footprint chart with
17 pre-programmed tools i talked about a
few today i talked about market sweeps i
talked about market
weakness i talked about um multiple
imbalances
and but there's more right this there's
total 17
programmed into the software and to set
it up is very easy you don't need any
templates or
you know spending hours you just set it
up the the defaults that are set is set
for the e-mini one-minute chart
normally i sell it for 8.99 on my
website but you're not going to pay that
today
you know having the software right
really the way i describe it it's like
having me sit next
to you on the desk right and taking what
i see
and basically telling you you know this
is bullish this is bearish
you know it takes the knowledge my
knowledge of trading
order flow that i learned you know 20
years as a
professional trader and put it into the
computer
right but i realized having software is
one thing you still need to know how to
use it
so i just said here's your software go
on your way figure it out you know which
a lot of people do right and
they've got these like yeah here's the
software that's going to solve all your
problems and they give you like a
a three-page pdf on on how to use it
you know and you're sitting there i just
spent all this money for this
for what um i provide a lot of education
right because you know i believe
you don't just need software you need to
know how to use it right sometimes i buy
software and it's like
okay but then i'm trying to figure out
how to use it
and then it's difficult right and i get
frustrated i don't want you to be
frustrated
so i give you access to my order flow
trading course which
i sell on my website you can go there
it's 297 if you want to just buy that
trading course but i'll give it to you
for free if you take advantage of the
special offer
now four or five years ago for about two
years i ran an inner circle
you know sort of advanced order flow
trading for traders
and what i'm gonna give you access to is
the videos
of that inner circle there's 56 videos
inside there again the inner circle
doesn't exist anymore
but you the videos still do so you're
going to get access to that
and what it is it's advanced order flow
analysis
ways to read the order flow you know
each video is about 30 to
50 minutes so it's not overwhelming but
again
it's fascinating you know parts of order
flow that you never probably
thought of looking at
normally if you want to access this to
this video series it's so five hundred
dollars it's 497.
okay i'll give you that for free also
because i really want you to understand
order flow not just have software but i
really want you to understand how to
trade the order flow
so you start adding it all up you know
that's almost seventeen hundred dollars
just 16.93
but again you know it's one thing to
learn from a course it's one thing to
learn from videos and books
it takes discipline and commitment right
and again it's hard for people
especially
if you got a family or if you're working
a job some cases two jobs
um it's difficult and that's why i do
live training sessions for people
um you know i do them every tuesday
night at 7 00 p.m i've done been doing
them since
2018 and
that's where you could come in you could
ask your questions if you have any
questions or you just sit back and chill
and just watch
and and learn right and there's over 116
episodes already in there and it's free
for users you could if you can't attend
you could watch the recording okay but
again you could ask questions
there that's that's why i do it is
because i want to have an area where you
could come in and interact with me
rather than trying to chase me down over
email you know if you got a question
that i maybe haven't addressed you want
me to explain something
i'll explain it here for you you just
come in and ask your question simple
right now there's people that charge you
want to charge you extra for
courses on how to use their software for
what you know
you just spent money on their software
they should be
helping you rather than you go to them
asking for help right that's why i do
this and it's why i don't charge you for
it
because again i want you to get up to
speed again you know other people will
charge you
200 up to 200 a month for training
on their software that you just bought
well the training should come with the
software
so you the software the trading course
the inner circle video series the live
training is it's it's
it adds up right but again you're not
gonna pay close to two thousand dollars
for this
right i got a special special deal it's
7.49 today
right again it is going up i've been
saying that for the last month i've been
really hesitant to
move the price up because my you know
other people involved are saying
you got it you got to raise the price
but i really want to keep it low to keep
people
you know get them into into trading all
right and again the beauty is
it's not a monthly recurring payment
right you pay 749 that's it for life
right and you get access to
the courses for life now
you will have to pay data fees and
whatever ninja trader fees now my
software will run on the free version
it'll run on the paid version
okay so if you're not using ninjatrader
you could get the free version connected
to a data source and you're good to go
you can enter your orders through
and you know your your other trader's
front end now
um if you're using a paid version a
ninjatrader if you have the full license
there is an order flow tool on there but
it's very basic
right people say well i got to buy your
software ninjatrader has
order flow on it well it has the
footprint on it
it doesn't have it doesn't tell you
what's happening in the order flow it
just shows you the order flow so there's
a big difference
okay so again you know other people have
been saying about my software is
it's very helpful because now they can
clearly see now what's happening in the
market
you know someone else says if you really
want to trade properly and understand
what on earth is happening in
any markets order flow is the path
forward and mike's experience and
explanation makes it click
so what you do is you go to
orderflows.com3
takes you to this page you scroll down
right
you see now there's videos you could
watch there's charts with explanations
you could read
but to really get started you just
scroll down find this button click here
to buy now get lifetime access to order
flows trader 3.0
right that's what you do to get started
okay now
it takes you to paypal paypal processes
it i don't get your credit card
information i don't want your credit
card information
it's all handled through paypal right
most people are familiar with paypal
and again it's just a one-time payment
of 7.49 again think about it right
where were you last year when shutdowns
hit right
versus where you are now you know we all
had a lot of plans things we wanted to
accomplish
you know like oh i'm gonna become a
better this or that and become a better
trader
are you now you know 749 is not a big
investment
in your future in your life so you got
several options
right one you can do nothing and stay
right where you are right now right
which is what i was talking about you
know versus last year then next year you
could do nothing now
the next year you could watch another
one of my presentations and sort of be
in the same spot that you are
literally right now going nowhere now
two
you could take the information i talked
about today and try to apply it to your
own trading
and you know maybe you can have some
success with it and maybe
you could have some success with it but
not understand
that you're doing it wrong okay i mean
some people take it
and they go away and they apply it
correctly to their training but there's
other people
sometimes they think they're doing it
correctly but they're not you know they
put the cart
before the horse instead of after the
horse so to speak
or number three work with me right
put the ball in the back of the net
score the goal so to speak right
take you step by step through the
process skip that trial and error of
trying to figure out order flow because
i'm teaching it to you
and you know then you'll notice your
trading improve
right and you'll hopefully your life
will improve right you become a better
better trader you're not going to be
stressed so much you know a lot of
traders get stressed because
they don't understand what's happening
in the market so they get stressed they
start to panic
i don't don't let that be you you know
you got to figure out what motivates you
in life you know for me it's freedom
right freedom to do what i want when i
want
with who i want right and
you know last year you know having that
freedom is like hey you know what we've
been in the house
since march basically
i want to go somewhere okay let's go to
south dakota we'll go see mount rushmore
go to crazy horse
those places okay let's go when you want
to go let's go now or
you know next week rather and that's how
we did you know we just filed everybody
in the car
and we we drove right why because i have
that freedom right i'm not tied down to
a boss or anything you know trading
gives you that freedom to go where you
want
when you want or basically do nothing if
you want if i just want to sit out and
vegetate
for a couple days i can do that right
the markets are going to be there
tomorrow and the next day
and the next year hopefully but
definitely they'll be there tomorrow
right they've been around since the
1800s the board of trade has been around
since 1863 or something like that
so it's well over 150 years so chances
are it's going to be there next year and
the year after that and the year after
that
right so you know trading is is a
long term
way to live basically
now i got a special you know for because
anna put together this
presentation for you guys i got a
special bonus for you guys right i'll
give you access to this course the order
flow
playbook normally i sell this for 297.
you can go to my website buy it now if
you want for 2.97 that's great
but we give it to you for free when you
get the software
right so again go to
orderflows.com3.html
but you really got to get started right
get i mean if you don't
get up and take some action nothing's
going to change for you right and
whether it goes for trading or anything
in life right so what you're going to
get
right you're going to get the order
flows trader software which is normally
8.99 you get
the order flow trading course which is
normally 297
the order flow inner circle video series
which is normally 4.97
the live weekly group training you can
be able to participate
you know the value for that you know in
my opinion is priceless
right and you get access to the order
flow playbook right which is normally
297 the oracle playbook actually gives
you
um nine or 11 trading setups
in addition to what i talked about today
that you could use in your trading
right but you don't get all that for
just a one-time payment again it's one
time i'm not gonna
charge your credit card every month and
then you you
can't cancel it then you gotta cancel
your credit card somehow you're still
getting charged i've been there
um you know i've i've set up recurring
payments for
things and then it's like i closed the
bank account but then the bank's still
chasing me down for money because
somehow it's
even though the bank account is closed
they're still processing payments it's
bizarre
but again and i hate that and i don't
want you go through that's why it's just
a one-time payment
there's no other payments to me in the
future just your data fees which i don't
get that just goes to
your data provider and whatever ninja
trader fees now if you stuck around
and a bunch of you have go to
orderflows.combook.html right it's going
to take you to this page make sure you
put
the book.html not just orderflows.com
book it's got to be order
www.orderflows.combook.html
enter your name and email address and
click submit and i'll take you to the
next page
which is the download right you can read
it online
you can download it to your handphone
your iphone or whatever
your tablet your computer print it up
it's yours for free so
again get started now go to oft.com
sorry orderflows.com3.html
and that's going to take you to the page
to get started so
um again i've put the information
in the chat so you know where to go the
links are there
in case you don't want to type it all in
there's the link for the book
http colon
backslash backslash www.orderflows.com
slash book.html and the other one is
orderflows.com oft 3
dot html and the reason why it's called
oft3 is because
we this is our third upgrade you know
when you get my software i don't charge
you for upgrades you know people that
have bought my software in 2015
2016 and are still using it right
because
they know they get the upgrades for free
they don't need to keep
paying more money you know and some
people want to keep charging oh we made
some changes so now we're going to
charge you more no
you know you bought it at this price
three years ago
you know even if it's more expensive now
you're still entitled
to all the upgrades for free so this is
our third
iteration you know this first one was
just order flows
off second one in 2018 was off
two this one is off three
and we do it about every two years so
you know
we're already in the works and working
with people on on what they want to see
in the next version of order flows
trader so
again you know i don't keep you guys on
too long i've been going on for an hour
and 15 minutes
so um you know if you've got any
questions just shoot me an email it's
mike
order flows.com and you know i'll do my
best to get back to you
in a timely fashion but um you know
granted i do get
a lot of emails but you know i you know
if you've got a legitimate question
i don't do free trials it was abused
before in the past
unfortunately we made a business
decision not to do it but again you know
we keep the value
not the value we keep the price of our
software relatively low
and the value high right we offer a lot
of tools and a lot of
extra education that you're just not
going to get elsewhere
okay and and really that's the
difference so
thanks everybody for attending thanks
anna for having me
and again you know any questions just
shoot me an email it's mike order
flows.com
and have a great rest of the week
everybody and
hope to hear from you guys soon bye bye
you